lance lynn on for his fourth start
when he got hurt he was unbelievably
good 27 strikeouts in 19 and two thirds
against just two walks
gonna be an outside fastball let's see
if he can throw it by loopy
oh he did
two down or hit a line drive rocket to
get it out today
in right field this could be rather
adventurous
high pop-up tim's going back robert's
coming in
and tim makes a catch and holds it up
like it was
the mvp trophy tristan mckenzie will be
the
starting pitcher for the tribe today
he'll make his fourth start his fifth
appearance
swing and a miss he got him with a
fastball one down
swing and a mess of the breaking ball in
the dirt hedges will have to throw to
first
he does two down swaying and a miss
threw the fastball buy him away
boy mckenzie what a start here is the dh
and if you were going to do the vote
he would be the unanimous american
league rookie of the year
jeremy mercedes
swing and a miss he struck him out
and five batters into the game the white
sox have yet to put a ball in play
now luis robert fastball blew it by him
tell you what tristan mckenzie is
literally
taking a page from shane bieber's
playbook so
three walks in the inning and two
strikeouts and it's up to leori garcia
way too high and the socks are on the
board
and now tim anderson
see if they can square one up here if
it's a
in the air right strike way back there
it was a grand slam
costa for everybody bring them all home
in a 5-0
they have been largely staying away from
tim almost the entire at-bat
last time he struck him out on a high
tide fastball but he set him up with the
entire
bat away this time tim looking outside
and he hits his fourth home run of the
year he had five runs batted in all
season
he has four with one swing of the back
andrei jimenez leads off the third
inning
as there's a fly ball to center and
robert will zigzag
and he will slide to make the catch well
the wind is batting it down
that's the thing you really don't know
which way it's going to go
because the wind is swirling and it bats
the ball down
jordan luplow will lead it off in major
league baseball as there's a ground ball
tim at short against luke lowe down the
line
jose on the pick beautiful on both ends
well tim realized he probably couldn't
keep it in the air all the way
and he made the off-balance throw
knowing if he got it there quickly it
would give jose a chance
to redirect himself and pick it to the
backhand with the indians trailing
five nothing in the top half of the
fourth inning
two down runner at first that's jose
ramirez
josh naylor the batter the two
hit hard and a base hit right field down
the line it goes
jose ramirez missed second base he's got
to go and re-tag it
and now they've got naylor hung up
they'll
throw behind ramirez and he gets in
there safely how do you like them apples
almost a disaster it works out okay
maybe he took his eye off it and wasn't
looking where he you know you got to hit
the base first
all right he went with his left foot not
his right he knows he missed it
and he says uh oh i better go back and
touch it and then i got to go on
no harm no foul if you get chang
chang sky's one shallow center it's
gonna drop a base hit
robert throws to third and bowers
is tagged out at third base
two runs score on the play
so the indians put two runs on the board
but bowers trying to go from first to
third
on a little floater that fell in he is
tagged out at third
here's garcia
down the line and right for larry garcia
yes bonnie's coming home hamilton speed
gets him there
too and it's a two-run double for leori
garcia
and a 7-2 sox lead three runs driven in
by liouri he takes it down the line he
now has 10 driven in
hedges popped to second his first time
up
hammered high in the air deep left field
hamilton back looking up
and goodbye austin hedges with his
second home run of the year
and it's a 7-3 ball game so hamilton who
came in as a pinch runner
will bat with the bases loaded in the
fifth
that'll in the inning white sox leave
them loaded
well a special day now for the sandlin
family
dad john mom daisy brother jake
girlfriend
jc mckenzie are all here to watch nick
sandlin
make his major league debut for the
tribe
sandlin's 24 years old and he really
was burning up the path to get to the
big leagues after they made him a second
round pick in 2018 out of southern miss
and a swing and a miss on a spider in
the dirt he got eaten again
hedges throws to third you talk about a
dream
scenario your major league debut nick
sandlin has a one two three inning
and he just got his first major league
strikeout
that could have been striking three side
inside it could have been strike three
didn't get the call and
somebody should be fined kangaroo court
ramirez with a heck of a play and they
call him safe
did bowers come off the bank now no safe
on the
i think they'll they'll check this one
it looked like he was out
he's out clearly out that will get
changed that shouldn't take it didn't
take long
oh [ __ ] he's out 7-3 sox with the lead
tim anderson a grand slam and aaron
bummer trying to finish this ball game
on the hill
on a brilliant day for baseball enjoying
the weather
enjoying the scoreboard and enjoying
one final cheer together we'll see two
and two
that is the end of the ball game
aaron bummer cleans it up 7-3 off at tim
anderson grand slam